a priest a rabbi and a comedian walk
into a YouTube studio that was once a
garage Bishop Robert Barron Rabbi David
Wolpe good to have you guys here good to
be here here I'm very happy to be doing
this because we are smack in between
Hanukkah and Christmas so it seemed like
the right time to get you two together
and I don't had you both on the show
individually and enjoyed them very much
and I thought let's have a let's have a
conversation about religion and meaning
and good social media and all sorts of
other things so first I thought we just
talked a little bit about the way that
people are talking about religion these
days I know that you both saw at least a
portion of my chat from a couple weeks
ago with Jordan Pederson advantage
Bureau Ben is obviously Orthodox Jew
Jordan comes through things through a
Christian perspective the idea though
that people that the average people out
there aren't necessarily getting the
messages that you guys talk about in the
traditional way and that they're getting
them in through YouTube videos and
podcasts and things like that what do
you make of that you know I'm pretty
good with it actually I think it's a
sign of our time and it's the way people
communicate and so those two gentlemen
have found a way you know as you have to
to use the social media very creatively
and if they can communicate some of the
truths of religion why not and also I
think with especially Jordan Peterson in
mind it's a smart presentation of
religious themes and speed on my own
tradition you know after Vatican 2 we
kind of dumb things down which I think
has been a pastoral disaster actually
and one reason we've lost like young
people we presented Catholicism a very
flat secularized unintelligent way and
Jordan Peterson is presenting you know
at least a version of religion a version
of a biblical interpretation in a very
compelling very intelligent way and look
how young people are responding to it
like mad I think that's a very hopeful
sign yeah what do you think I think that
the twist is that you know we were
talking right before the show started
about people that have debated and the
Harrises to some extent but much more
the Hitchens of blessed memory and and
others would take
take religion Richard Dawkins and say it
is this collection of ridiculous dogmas
and and nothing worthwhile in anything
that is worthwhile in it we have in the
secular world better and the
counter-argument well you don't
necessarily have to buy all of religion
to realize that the themes are deep and
complicated and inspiring and beautiful
and I think that they're being framed
that way I mean I don't know I'm not
sure you know I'm not sure he knows what
exactly Peterson's religious commitment
is but one thing that is clear is that
he and many of the people who listen to
him and follow him take religious themes
ideas and sometimes even scriptural
stories as indicative of something
deeper about the nature of the world do
you think that's enough I mean as enough
for what enough for for just a human not
just someone that's publicly talking
about this but is that rich enough to
just take the shelves and the stories
without okay so some of the mighty my
principal concern as somebody who's
associated with institutional religion
which is like a metamer to many people
right is when someone tells me for
example that they are spiritual but not
religious what I always want to say to
them is how much do you give to charity
because to have your own life enriched
but for it not to be expressed in
conduct is not enough so the question
that I would always have is in what way
does he influence the way you treat
other human beings how charitable you
are whether you're a part of a community
and you both take from that community
but also contribute to it if it does all
of those things then I'm much more
persuaded that it's effective if all it
does is get you to attend a lecture read
a book and feel like you've been
elevated then it's not enough yeah I
suspect you probably agree with the
premise there yeah it's not enough I
mean I think it's a good starting point
to me what Jordan Peterson does what the
Bible is similar to what the Church
Fathers in our tradition quoted call the
moral sense of the scripture so you look
at the Bible a number of ways and one is
to uncover it's it's important for moral
behavior we might say today for our
psychology you know good wonderful but
there's a lot of other dimensions to
read in the Bible
the Bible make certain objective claims
about God and it takes the New Testament
about Jesus about eternal life you know
and I think that's not touched on so
much by Jordan Peterson now again I
don't want a badmouth and I think it's a
very good starting point for a lot of
people it's a way in why not begin with
the moral psychological sense but then
I'd say keep going you know and finally
you do have to make metaphysical claims
it seems to me in the religious realm
you can't simply leave it at the level
of subjective appropriation you have to
say is it true that God exists is it
true that God's the creator of all
things and in the case of Christianity
is it true that the God sent His only
Son that we might have life in his name
so you have to wrestle with those
metaphysical issues but I'm flying with
him as a as a opening of a door you know
so it's so interesting to me that people
actually care about a debate about the
nature of truth you know it's like you
live in a time when everyone's on
Twitter all day we can be distracted by
video games and it kajillion other
things yeah and yet somehow through that
you know that video that we did has over
a million views already and a couple
hundred thousand on the audio podcast
and it's a two-hour conversation about
these things so one of the things that
we really focused on was the sort of
what I think they would both argue are
the bedrock values of a judeo-christian
society so when someone says that to you
since I have someone from the Judeo
embarrassing part here what does that
actually mean to you when someone says
the values of the judeo-christian
Society I think deep respect for the
dignity of the of the individual made in
the image and likeness of God the call
to justice the call to peace the call to
non-violence the call to love the call
of a compassion I'd see all that as the
great trajectory of the biblical
revelation you know those are the
behavioral implications of the more
profound metaphysical claims but I see
all that we have very much in common and
any one in a biblical frame of mind
would see those things yeah I completely
agree and I think that the the
implication of the the second half what
the bishop was saying is that there is
and this is one of the reasons I think
why why Ben and Jordan communicate so
effectively as they agree about this
that truth is not actually the truth is
an objective concept that exists
as opposed to something that's entirely
the invention of human beings in a
relative sense and depending on time and
place and that doesn't mean that you
have easy access to it you may never in
fact understand it but even the
statement that there is such a thing as
a truth is in our time somewhat
countercultural so one of the things
that we talked about was this has been
argued by many people but Jordan and
that conversation was talking about it
that there's a sense right now that all
the good ideas of the world of freedom
and the individual and all of those
things came from the Enlightenment now
I'm an Enlightenment guy go into my room
over there every book is from an
Enlightenment thinker some of these
books right here are but as a guy who's
debated some of the people or I have
written some of these books that have
been in this room I suspect you would
argue that the enlightenment values
alone which I suppose you hold many of
sure or it weren't enough right is that
is that I would say first of all they
have more religious roots than the
radical enlightenment theorists admit to
yeah explain that a little bit sure I
mean when you talk about for example the
dignity of the individual which is very
much an Enlightenment idea well the
first statement about human nature in
the Bible is that a human being is
created in the image of God so I mean I
hate to say for every good eye oh we had
it first but we clearly have that first
um we being you know anybody who
associates themselves with this
tradition and also by the way to be fair
you know I've traveled in the East you
find many of these ideas in places where
the Enlightenment never took hold so to
argue like I Jonathan Israel does who's
an Enlightenment historian that these
are all legacies of the Enlightenment
well what about India what about you
know Southeast Asia where many of these
ideas also have currency although in
different form and the second part of it
is that the Enlightenment you know the
Enlightenment was a was a mixed bag the
French Revolution was a horrible
bloodbath just as Burke had predicted it
would be and part of it was because the
Enlightenment was not so much about many
of the values that I think we are
rediscovering of community charity
mutual interdependence that
are that are much more associated with
religious communal work than they are
with enlightenment ideas yeah
the underpinning part it's very close to
my own perspective on it you know part
of the problem is you say the
Enlightenment well of course who's
against light
everyone wants lightness but the IMP is
the implication is well prior to that
must have been just those terrible dark
ages that's all a distortion because
you're dead right I mean I'd say the
best of the Enlightenment was a sort of
representation of key ideas out of the
great biblical tradition so human
dignity is one but think of you know
Jefferson we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal because look in classical
political philosophy equality is not a
huge value in fact in Plato and
Aristotle Cicero people like that
inequality is fundamental and the
rightly ordered society you know takes
into account all these deep inequalities
where's that idea come from how come
it's totally non self-evident to
Aristotle but it's totally self-evident
to Jefferson what intervened in here but
but the judeo-christian revelation you
know freedom equality human rights
they're endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights so that to me
is the the after-effects of Christian
and Jewish revelation that that's the
best of the Enlightenment and then the
Enlightenment does carry a dark side
excuse the you know mixing your
metaphors but it does hyper
individualism a hyper rationalism
a certain closing in upon a purely
scientific view of the world all of that
is the dark side of the Enlightenment so
I would just look at it you know
critically appreciating huge elements of
it which I think fundamentally are
grounded in the scripture and then being
wary of certain you know negative
qualities of it so I says maybe there's
a little disagreement there just because
of the way Jews generally have viewed
science perhaps a little bit differently
like well like a hyper hyper scientific
view of the world usually doesn't become
in conflict with well depends on age of
really just you know I think for example
I mean the vast majority of Jews even
religious Jews don't find evolution to
be but that's today don't find evolution
to be in conflict
with the Bible although some would but
not but fewer and I think that Judaism
is hospitable to science as a general
rule what I would say though it emerges
from the discussion is what you started
with which is why is it that people are
hospitable to these sorts of discussions
now the answer is because we have a
world in which human power is magnified
far beyond anything we ever could have
imagined before to cure disease to I
mean it's like I you know when I was in
high school I was a pretty avid atheist
and I read and memorized most of
Bertrand Russell and I remember Russell
writing in one of his books
people used to say the faith moved
mountains and no one believed it now
they say the atom mom moves mountains
and everyone believes it and that was
the hyper scientific view well now we
have a world in which you can manipulate
genes you can artificial intelligence is
doing increasingly remarkable things and
I think people are recognizing not only
recognizing but their feeling on a gut
level if we don't know what our first
principles are this genie out of the
bottle is going to destroy us so you
don't fear a hyper scientific world as
long as it comes within the context I
fear like like every person I almost
want to rope in every thoughtful person
I fear our information outrunning our
wisdom yes but as long as it doesn't
then I don't fear it and that's closely
my own view about scientism I'm all in
favor of the sciences and I always try
to celebrate the fact that you know
George lameta a priest formulated the
BIGBANG theory of cosmic origins I mean
so the myth that the Catholic Church
stands against the sciences is just that
it's a myth Mendel yeah right I mean
there's so many people Copernicus
himself you know but scientism is the
reduction of all knowledge to the
scientific form of knowledge and that is
a dark side of enlightenment if you say
that's the sum total what we can know
legitimately we know through the
scientific method when in fact
literature the Bible drama poetry
philosophy all that is is a bearer of
wisdom but it's not scientific but I
find dealing with the young people today
scientism is
and so that the binary option is science
or nonsense religion clearly not science
therefore now read Hitchens Dawkins and
company you're finding that binary
choice so I want to fight in favor of
other ways of knowing that are not
scientific do you both sense that the
resurgence of these ideas and and the
starvation to just hear people talk
about these things honestly is also sort
of a failure of the secular world is
been in Jordan this and I hate the
question because I I believe so much in
the secular world and I and I love
secular ideas that that free us and all
of these things but that's sort of
there's a feeling right now and I think
it has something to do with social media
and that our public squares have become
sort of they're open which is great but
then I've also become forums for
hysteria and fake news and all of these
things that it's a sort of failure of
the secular world oh go ahead please I'm
yes I'm not sure which world hasn't
failed but the secular world certainly
has and it has in part because of
exactly what we've been saying which is
once again remove first principles from
the discussion what's the only thing you
can be certain of the only thing you can
be certain of is your own emotional
reaction that bothers me therefore it's
bad and so what you get is as you said
this hyper hysterical reaction everybody
is a group to be offended because I this
is what I feel and the idea that we can
share principles and discuss them has
sort of disappeared scholasticism
Talmudic argument the things that we
made are you know we cut our teeth on
they don't exist because there's no
shared space in which we can all agree
about the same thing which is why
because culture and and literature and
music all of them are not sure they're
all balkanized and the only thing that
we all share is politics so everything
gets politicized so that's exactly what
my next question was gonna be which is
our politics our new religion and how
actually dangerous is that yes super
dangerous I mean I would say with Paul
Tillich who said you know religions your
ultimate concern so everyone's got a
religion meaning there's something
that's an ultimate value to you I put in
biblical language something that you
worship you know worship comes from
Worth
ship what's of highest worth to you and
you can until ik said all you need to
know about a person you can find out by
asking one question what do you worship
and that's absolutely right it seems to
me I mean what's the highest-valued you
when it's not God then we get mischief
so put whatever you want in that place
science or politics or culture or a
president or whatever trouble Bible
calls it idolatry by the way you know so
that diagnosis is still altogether valid
and yes if politics becomes your
ultimate concern that's gonna be bad for
you for everyone in the conversation and
for politics politics will become
corrupt you know that that sort of
explains the political situation it does
in many ways right and so that's that's
the trouble see with a secularism that
creates what Charles Taylor called the
buffer itself right the self that's in
this little self-contained place
buffered from any contact with the
transcendent that becomes suffocating
and there's another shadow side if you
want of a hyper rationalistic view of
the world would you both argue that on
and I think I probably asked you both
this individually but I'm sort of
struggling with this one this has been
where I'm at lately that on a micro
level on a personal level say a Michael
Shermer right here or Sam Harris right
here could be absolutely moral and
decent and give to charity and live full
rich lives that are every bit as
meaningful as it as any believer but
that perhaps at the macro level that
simply can't I think I mean Sam is a
good example I Sam takes his morality
extremely seriously as you know and and
what I would say is that the there is
there is what a the mid twentieth
century Jewish philosopher will Herbert
called cut flower ethics yeah he said
they stay fresh for a while but the
question is without the soil that
nurtured them how long does that stay
and so yeah you can get individual
growths that are as beautiful as any
growths that ever existed but the
question is transmissibility and and the
thickness of the culture in which you
know I mean if you look around the
Western world I think there's a lot of
evidence that in fact ethics aren't that
effectively transmitted and part of the
reason is because there is no soil
there's no grounding there's no
certainty if you for even wanted to
introduce ethical education into school
systems people would scream yeah and yet
without ethical education all the other
things are imperiled so it was helpful
I've used that image before it never
knowing where it came from
I'll cut flowers saying because it's
really good yeah you know we for a while
oh sure the country is kind of going on
the fumes of of a religious system but
if you take those flowers out of the
ground they are gonna fade so that's who
was it again will Herbert you're a
Protestant Catholic Jew century that's
right yeah by the way I would also say
that that I then I think again I'm sure
that the I'm sure that the bishop would
I suspect the fishing pole didn't agree
with me I'm gonna get to someday Tory is
that religion doesn't mean that you have
to walk into my synagogue mm-hmm
you should but it doesn't mean that you
asked it right no but seriously religion
has reinvented in all sorts of ways I
mean my my niece's husband is one of the
one one of the people high up in Burning
Man and there's a lot that goes on there
that has a serious like a serious
religious component even though they may
not call it religion the question is can
society reinvent religion or take from
religion and reconfigure it in ways that
are enduring and lasting and meaningful
it doesn't have to be at small Oh
orthodoxy
so I got a good philosophical one for ya
if somebody could come up with that
would you guys be against it if someone
could come up with that bedrock that
would allow those fresh-cut flowers to
stay and stay and say a new version of
all of this may be felt more
contemporary or something like that but
it edit and it gave all of the answers
that that you are these here you may
come across a disagreement because
Judaism is not solely morals and
behaviors it's also a people in a
history and a land and a language and
lots of other things and that is not
going to get replaced by somebody coming
up with an ethical system right so what
I've seen the ground finally is God
you know so come on God what you want
it's the unconditioned the unconditioned
true good and beautiful that's God and
that's the ground for these great
ethical commitments I used to I never
met Christopher Hitchens but you know
I've read him and watched him carefully
and I was always struck by the intensity
of his ethical commitments was to me
seemed incoherent in light of a
completely atheistic view of the world
but there was a Jeremiah like passion
for ethical and I would say look that's
it that's the door in if you want you
can do cosmological type argument so
it's had very little traction with
Hitchens but my way in for him was
follow your own ethical passion
you're gonna come funny what I mean by
God which is the unconditioned good you
don't want just any old justice you want
justice all the time you want just as in
every way you want you want justice to
fill the whole earth you know that's a
hunger and thirst for God I think what
if they put it there well what is that
nobody the right answer is is that
they're already there see it's not that
they're trying to get there it's you've
already been seized by God if you've got
that passion for justice that's God
already working in you you know so it's
not so much the quest for God out there
but God's already grasped you at the
root of your being and filled you with
this prophetic passion so I would say in
a way he's already been found you know
so let's get to some of the the
differences here so we're talking about
judeo-christian values you know but
those are not exactly the same thing so
what maybe each of you could pick
perhaps one thing now I guess Judi is
our game first not I guess but
Christianity differ which is in
vicarious atonement in the Jewish
tradition if you don't make reparations
to the person whom you've hurt God can't
forgive you that's a big difference I
mean and this was illustrated most
famously not exclusively but most
famously when one of the prosecutors at
Nuremberg asked the priest does that
mean that if say iseman repented on his
deathbed and accepted jesus he would be
forgiven and saved but an Frank would go
to hell and the priest said that's the
mystery of grace
that's a
reference mm-hmm if I were to name a
difference its its Christ is the
difference so I wouldn't on reduce
things to ethics we find all kinds of
common ground when it comes to ethics
but I'd resist the Conte and move to
reduce religion to ethics I mean it's a
dimension of it it's a it's a
consequence of it the difference is is
Jesus you know and Jesus means the
coming together of divinity and humanity
in such a way that humanity is
transfigured and brought up into a share
in the divine life and that's the
mystical heart of Christianity from that
flows all kinds of ethical you know
implications but that's the central
mystery I think is divinization the
Greek father's called theosis the Latins
call it DF Acacio that God became one of
us that we might become a sharer in his
own life and the Jews call it false
that's why to call someone a Jew for
Jesus is an oxymoron because that was
actually the critical dividing line
between Jews and Christians was the
acceptance of Jesus as divine or the Son
of God or the Messiah so what so what do
you see you saw wrong isn't the right
term but what do you see is conflicting
with your values okay with Jews values
so first of all a human being doesn't
become God in the Jewish tradition God
is transcended and the imminent but
always intangible and that does not take
human form never took human form and
also even though Christianity talks
about three and one and one and three I
remember when I was in high school when
we had a Baptist preacher come to our
high school and told us he's you know
you seem like nice boys and girls but
you're all going to hell and I asked him
I said well if something is perfect it
doesn't need anything added to it so was
the father perfect and he said yes and I
said we're done we're done we don't know
anything else yeah that's I mean that's
been the Jewish view and but I but I
also want to say this is an argument
that has gone on for a thousand years
and every now and then I'll get someone
on my facebook and say what about this
verse and I'll think really yeah well
that's why it's almost it almost feels a
little silly for me to frame a question
like that but I know I know that people
watching don't want you guys
and sort of yeah on every shirt know you
disagree on the margins or you just are
people of different faiths right and
that's just fine but I think there's
always like this feeling of like unless
there's some core thing that is not
argued about that that we're missing
something I don't I like religious
argument and do it publicly is a good
thing yeah and like I found it I've been
involved in many we're putting this on
YouTube and the commenters are very kind
well believe me but I've been involved
in a lot of Catholic Jewish dialogues
over the years we hardly ever mentioned
the J word by which I mean Jesus right
so we tend to say it's great that were
nice to each other and we've overcome
these old you know animosities and we
stand for the great ethical principles
which is great and true and I never ever
want to go back behind it
but I would say well now what about
Jesus let's talk about Jesus and then
people get very squirrely now I
certainly understand given our rather
regrettable history on this thing you
know that we're always worried about
religious violence I get it at the same
time I think it's it's a desideratum
that we'd find a way to have a
respectful and nonviolent argument I
think arguments a good thing and as you
say quite rightly that doesn't bother
you rabbinic tradition the scholastic
tradition they love arguments times
acquaintances I mean argues with
everybody right there's something very
Talmudic about Thomas Aquinas and I
think that's a great thing that we need
to recover
there's something very urban about
Aquinas you know he a theology had moved
out of the monasteries into the cities
into place like Paris there was a lot of
you know different points of view and
people shouting things from the from the
floor and his writings reflect that
lively sort of conversation I like that
I think it's a healthy thing you know
well I think that really explains what's
happening on YouTube these days with
conversation I mean well that's what
brought you guys here and the
fascination with religion now it's often
done poorly God knows there's people
often just sharing a lot of you know
strong feelings but I like the fact
there's obviously great interest in
religion yeah so I thought this would be
interesting I know you can't obviously
tell me what your the people of your
congregation are coming to you with
privately but I wonder if there's
general trends that maybe are the same
or different that you both are hearing
about so I wonder if you could sort of
tell me just a general trend of the type
of things that people are struggling
right now sure I would say and have you
seen that change let's say 20 years I
would say increasingly the trend is
finding a partner being lonely I think
there is I think we are I mean you know
he wrote I don't know how many years ago
Putnam wrote the book Bowling Alone but
I think we're Bowling Alone more and
more and more and the more effective
technology becomes the more we can
insulate ourselves in cocoon ourselves
against it against the world you can you
know order your food in and you can
watch whatever you want and and yet
there is this deep human desire for
connection the problem is the connection
takes work and it takes effort and so in
some ways we're becoming a less
effortful society and therefore a
lonelier society I get a lot of that and
then there are all the range of human
problems family problems marriage
problems and meaning problems I I think
there's a sense in which you just like
all the commandments could be reduced to
do not steal because all of them are a
form of stealing in one way or another
all human problems can be reduced to I
don't have meaning because other people
give you meaning community gives you
meaning a good job gives you meaning a
spouse that loves you I mean you know
meaning is sort of it's the ground it's
the tilaka and ground of being that
we're all looking for yeah yeah what
about for you is sort of trans yeah what
I would find both in my ministry as a
bishop but also kind of the online work
that I do in evangelization is the
meaning thing because the stats are all
showing you know when I was a kid back
in the 70s about 3% of our country would
have said I have no religion
I mean 97% of the country would have
said I'm religious now maybe not
ardently so but ninety-seven percent had
a religious affiliation now it's 25
percent among young people it's 40
percent among young Catholics of 30 and
younger it's 50 percent now say I have
no religion and that expresses itself as
a very deep hunger and alienation and I
sense that all the time
people want truth they want meaning they
want religious purpose but it's the cut
flowers thing that more and more they're
losing contact with the sources of that
and it's causing enormous existential
suffering
Pope has talked about the existential
margins I like that you know the church
goes out to the margin he says economic
and political margins but he also named
the existential margins people that are
cut off from God and I find that all the
time more than when I started thirty
some music but also I wonder what you
think about the fact that that's true
here and it's true certainly true for
Jews here I mean there's no difference
but elsewhere in the world that's not
true yeah there are parts of the world
where religious affiliation exploded
that's right in the West is right
exactly but in the West it isn't right
so what's the what's the pivot what's
the difference well in some ways you
know it's from modernity to
postmodernity you might say that shadow
of enlightenment finding more and more
expression you know if a hyper
rationalism a scientistic view of the
world the buffer itself of all that is
taking more and more root in people's
psyches that's going to happen you know
the alienation will be deeper as you say
a lot of other societies around the
world religion is still very strong and
growing but I think in the West that's
it's the it's the after-effects of
modernity and probably post modernity
so I also I want to bring in Aldous
Huxley here doesn't have that far to go
ya know in brave new world which I have
to say I think about all the time as I
read about China hmm yeah they're
including these policies they're
instituting these policies that increase
authoritarianism but they're making
people they're satisfying the basic
needs that people have I think that
increasingly as you satisfy certain
basic needs that people have they will
give up on everything else that they
don't absolutely have to have so I mean
this is why there's that great speech in
in in brave new world anywhere he says I
want god I want sin I want messiness I
want unhappiness people are opting out
of that because the truth is when people
come to a synagogue or to a church and
they say you know there's a it's so hard
and I you know the place is too
political too political by the way
always means I didn't get what I wanted
what political always means nobody gets
what they want and says this to
political funding what they're saying is
the friction of dealing with other human
beings in uncomfortable ways is
something I don't have to put up with so
I won't I'll text instead of call you
know when I was when when when all of us
were younger they used to say about a
telephone that it gave you intimacy
without danger
because you could talk on the phone but
you'd have to face the person now it's
like multiplied many times texting gives
you into there is actually danger but
not the kind of danger of facing someone
and so we created all these technologies
that are like soma to make people to low
people Inc the individual comfort and
we're paying a tremendous price so is
this the irony though I mean what brings
us the three of us together is the
Internet right yeah yeah it's this
incredibly powerful thing that now is is
spreading the messages that guys care
about is also the very force that is
allowing for us to be you know alone
when we're and surrounded by so much
always goes with all things humans I
mean this both couldn't bet and you
mentioned Huxley I'll mention Tierra de
chardin you know they create Jesuit
scientists theologian but he talked
about the noosphere he dreamed of this
next stage of evolution where the whole
planet would be connected through a sort
of brain like structure and it seems so
fantastic back in the 1950s well it's
happened were the results of it we're
participating in it
and there's something beautiful about
that he he dreamed of the sense of
connection that we're gonna have and we
do have that I mean I I'd want to stress
the positive side of Internet and social
media and all that stuff's terrific in
many ways but like all things human and
biblical people know that it's gonna go
bad you know in time sin is gonna
reassert itself and the thing will be
corrupted in some ways but but the
positive remains and I love it I love
the noosphere I think it's a positive
development yeah it's interesting
because I've had obviously you both on
individually we both got into hot water
from different communities online after
we chatted because I had you on and I
had people say on the left who were
angry that I even sat down with the
bishop Yeah right yeah i sat down with
the bishop and you told me church
doctrine and then
a little bit about your personal
feelings and people were just annoyed
that I even sat down with your first
place you got into a lot of hot water
because you said something to the effect
of your head in your heart not behave
exactly the same place with this and you
had so then you had people say more on
the right or more traditional or
whatever you want to call that angry at
you and I thought we must have done
something right here because we're both
getting you know hate so to speak from
different quarters and that that's sort
of the beauty and the horrors of the
internet yeah and I mean I've sent it
from the very beginning when I started
doing work on YouTube and as I say I
didn't even know you could comment I was
that naive about YouTube I put things up
there and I'm just inundated with these
negative comments because you know the
vast majority people we all know don't
write in to say black really weren't
saying yeah
97% are going after you but I mean now
I'm used to it and I like it because I
get some traction you know I can't all
right at the very least now I can find
some way to engage you and talk to you I
got to remind myself all the time
there's a person behind those those are
harsh words you know that's somebody
maybe in his mom's basement or who knows
where he is or she is but somebody was
writing those words as as vicious and
cruel as they might be so it's a
pastoral opportunity I mean I wouldn't
want to miss that and I've encouraged
you know my students this is the cutting
edge of pastoral ministry in many ways
we've got to learn how to engage that
world very creatively and we're missing
a giant opportunity so it's interesting
this just talking about the gay marriage
issue for a minute which it's already
legal here I don't even really like
belaboring it because it seems like the
ship has sailed and most people are
basically okay with it at this point
Jews sort of were ahead on this
generally speaking yes generally
speaking or at least secular Jews right
now right you had a little bit of an
insurrection again in your own time when
you took a position Pro gay marriage so
so what is the well what is it is it is
it about the history of Jews being the
other or something else that allow Jews
generally to evolve on social issues a
little sure this is a really interesting
question about why
tend to be I mean 80% of Jews find
themselves on the left of the political
spectrum that has shifted somewhat in
the last I don't know 20 30 years but
it's still true and there's been a lot
of diagnosis about why that is
whether it's lamentation from the right
or a cheering from the left right um I
think know a bit about it right exactly
so I think that there is a lot of
discussion in in society right now is
about the perception of the other and I
think Jews have an instinctive other
Ness there's a phrase in the in the
Bible that's that uses the word Garrett
Oh Shaw which means a resident alien and
a classic commentary on it says this is
how you should always feel in the world
like you're both resident and alien and
I think that that's been the Jewish
historical experience they always felt
like they didn't entirely belong so when
they see someone else who doesn't
entirely belong there's an instinctive
sympathy that gets played out that way
and and I think that that is still true
for most Jews and even Jews on who would
find themselves on the right in this
would still say that they they have that
instinctive sympathy it expresses itself
in different ways so that right now I'm
Jewish yeah that rings very true to me
does that so Christianity which has been
more of a style jority religion let's
say you wouldn't inherently feel that do
you think no I think there's a tension
what you're talking about you know is
obviously a deeply biblical intuition
about compassion for the other and
especially for someone on the margins of
all that's there I think that and
Catholic teaching reflects that the deep
compassion for everybody at the same
time a natural law tradition that comes
up not just out of Greek philosophy but
out of biblical sources and the nature
of marriage and the integrity of the
sexual act etcetera etcetera I mean all
that is deeply biblical in its origins
it's it's supported by the philosophical
tradition and let's face it there was a
consensus of the peoples up until about
25 years ago that this was the right way
to understand marriage sexuality so I I
would want to you know characterize the
church's position as somehow retrograde
or were so behind the times it's it's
coming up out of this very tradition we
were
you know so I'd make that distinction
between defending the integrity of
marriage classically defined and
reaching out with love and compassion
and non-violence and welcome to
everybody you know I think that's the
the place the church wants to find us so
here's all right here's a hard and
perhaps unpopular thing to say but
you're exactly right that it was only in
the 1980s that Andrew Sullivan wrote
about gay marriage it's very recent in
the span of history and and you see this
dynamic being played out again and again
so for example when my daughter went to
college which was she's just graduating
so four years ago the first questions
they asked them was what's your name
give us a favorite animal and what is
your preferred gender pronoun so some
people said call me them for example and
got very offended like it got very
offended would someone would say you
yeah and I'm in discussions with her I
was saying to her you know yeah I
understand why people who are young
don't yet get what it is to grow up and
be oriented a certain way they won't
until they're my age and then there will
be something else that a young person
will ask them that they won't be able to
do but there has to be a circle of
compassion here which I understand is
hard for people who feel themselves not
accepted but they have to realize to
some extent that people are trained in
lots of deep ways and I first learned
this I took my junior year abroad in
Scotland and there was this guy who made
a really aunt didn't know I was Jewish
made a really anti-semitic remark so I
started to talk to him I did exactly
what you said I didn't time was not a
pastor but I didn't took it as an
opportunity and after several
discussions he said to me you know I
worshipped my father and my father
always told me when Jews were terrible
and it's so hard for me to see them
because I feel like I'm betraying my
father and it was the first time I
really understood that you can be
trained in such a way that it's hard to
get out of and that the victim in quote
of your training has to have a certain
amount of compassion for the time it
takes for others to adjust that's
powerful what are some of the other
issues that
people are coming to you about well the
one I sense the multi say is this quest
for for God and it's a hunger and thirst
for God I would just use the most
fundamental religious language I can
find people are dissatisfied with the
goods of the world and especially in the
West they have them in huge quantities
they have all the wealth and pleasure
and power and honor they can get it in
many cases and then they're desperately
unhappy and they want something which
the world can't give they want something
the scientists can't give they want
something secularism can't give and so
in a way there is a great opportunity
now it seems to me for religious people
to again publicly reassert the great
spiritual tradition so how important
that I guess I was just gonna saying one
of the things we have lost is the
capacity to be creatively unhappy
because for most of human history that
wasn't what I mean the pursuit of
happiness made most people did not
assume that they had a right to be happy
and in fact being unhappy was one of the
Wellsprings of creativity and art and
literature and and social movements and
so on and I think now because our
mechanisms for alleviating acute
unhappiness are so good both medically
and socially I think we've a little bit
lost the capacity to be unhappy so the
founding fathers kind of burdened us
with the pursuit to be happy about that
to me it's very enlightenment sort of
thing is if Jefferson didn't define
happiness he said we have a right to
pursue it according to our own you know
will prior to them to that period
what preoccupied the minds of the great
thinkers was well what is happiness you
know so whether it's Aquinas or it's
Cicero or it's Plato is Aristotle
they're deeply interested in what makes
us happy there's a shift at modernity
that says well we don't really know
what's gonna make us happy but you
pursue it your way you pursue it that
way and we have a right to do it but I
think that question still it's it haunts
the human heart and well important do
you think the question it's it's the
only question that finally matters I
mean what do you think that's more
important than the question of meaning
it is the question of meaning it is the
question the same thing what makes me
find what gives me be attitude oh now
that doesn't mean psychological
contentment
quite agree with Revere I mean we're not
gonna get psychological commitment very
often and I think you're out right then
it's an engine of progress the fact that
we don't have psychological contentment
the attitude oh is is the joy of the
heart or its Shalom or it's this peace
at the level of the soul that people
want I won't get it perfectly in this
life you know I aspire to it perfectly
in the in the life to come but it's deep
in me to want it and that's what drives
me you know and if you suppress that say
John of the Cross of it have you
suppressed that very dangerous things
happen psychologically and spiritually
and I think you see that all over the
place now that question is unimportant
don't worry about that question seek
wealth pleasure honor power secret
scientists can tell you but that's not
gonna satisfy the longing of the heart
and yeah
shimon peres who was the President of
Israel Prime Minister briefly said the
great contribution of the Jews to the
world was dissatisfaction and if you
think about it I mean if people like
towards the end of their life they you
ask them when they were happiest it
wasn't once they achieved the goal that
they were it's always on the way there
and yeah I mean there is something about
unhappiness that makes you happy
strange sounds yeah well it gives you
drive it right I mean those are the
moments that you think of nostalgically
yeah but how important so you said it's
the same question
I'm soul meaning the pursuit of
happiness in the group and the pursuit
of morality of meaning of meaning yeah
do you think that's the side question
and well I wouldn't know I wouldn't use
the word happy I would say the pursuit
of meaning I mean you can be deeply
troubled pained and and you wouldn't
call yourself happy and yet you would
say I'm where I'm supposed to be and
this is I'm looking for a different word
because happy has connotation I agree
right right this the psychological
content exactly something too trivial
almost like here's the interesting dance
I quite agree with you on that Aquinas
says for example you want to see a
picture of beatitude oh so the latin for
happiness
he said you look at the crucified Jesus
because Jesus on the cross wealth
pleasure honor power he's got none of
them no no they're all stripped away but
he's doing the will of his father and so
he says paradoxically that's a picture
of a happy man now's no psychological
contentment what
ever on the country but yet we hold that
image up in in Catholic churches anyway
and we want people to contemplate that
image you know
so not a picture of someone wealthy
someone powerful someone full of
psychological pleasure we hold up the
crucified Jesus and we say that's
beatitude oh that's what you're seeking
you know to be stripping away of many
buildings so self-sacrifice is somebody
be sacrifices themselves happy
I don't think happy is the right or
right is the right word you know but if
there is something right exactly yes
how about Shalom something fulfilled ya
mean and maybe right are you both
constantly amazed at just what people
can put up with that they don't think
they can that people come to you with
disease or death or whatever it is
you lost their job who's in the house
the whole thing and and they think
everything's falling apart and that you
know in most cases they always make it
through one way or another that must be
one of the things that you both find
that it gotta give you so much so I just
just a couple months ago I did the
funeral of max Webb who died at a
hundred won and he had survived a teen
concentration camps and he was a
remarkable just a remarkable man and and
he would I mean he when he when the
Nazis came to his town he said to his
mother if you hear that I was shot or
hung it might be true if you hear that I
starve don't believe it
hmm and that's what he was like he just
had a life force that was indomitable
and what he put up with in his life was
you know literally unimaginable to
someone who didn't go through a similar
experience and so yes when I look at
that and I see and he was I think he
genuinely most of the time a happy man
mm-hmm and I think that that's because
there was no question in his life in his
in his mind that life was meaningful
that God was real that miracles were
real that his survival had a purpose
that he had to commemorate the people
who didn't survive I mean in some ways
his life was more peopled by the people
who weren't there then for most of us by
the people who are what do you
get up to that a young person though a
child you know how old he was exactly
what that happened yeah he was that he
could that a young person could have
that you haven't had the time to think
okay so I think part of it I mean part
of it is intrinsic nature there are
people who are you know there are people
who are fortunate enough to be to have
that god-given resilience and then I
think that part of it was the the
furnace that he went through that
refined his character and made him
determined not to have lived in vain it
reminds me of so just a quick story hugo
grin who was a rabbi in in britain when
he was a child he was in Auschwitz and
his father
it was Hanukkah we've just finished
Hanukkah so his father took the
margarine ration and he used it to light
the Hanukkah menorah and green who was
like 11 or 12 at the time
like screamed at his father and said how
can you we're supposed to be eating this
this is our food this is what survives
his father said my child we've learned
that you can live for three weeks
without food you can live for three days
without water but you can't live for
three minutes without hope so the people
who learned that lesson were different
is ultimately concerned yeah I mean
you're up against it as a religious
figure all the time you're up against
suffering from the very beginning every
when I was newly ordained I'm 26 years
old you know and I was in the funeral
directors car behind the third hearse of
that week I was doing my third funeral
that week and I remember thinking what
am i doing I'm 26 years old this is
beautiful day I'm behind my third you
know but you do it because it those are
those limit experiences where people
have a sense of God it's often when
pushed to those limits just you know
recently I'm not hearing him sunny
beautiful Southern Californian all my
Chicago friends are oh they're - IDO on
Santa Barbara look where Santa Barbara
gets the terrible Thomas fire followed
by the even more terrible mudslide that
killed 20 people in one night I was at a
funeral of a man who lost his wife and
two kids in that mudslide so that that's
what is you know I mean we go there we
always go to those places were called to
stand in those places and have that
awful responsibility and awful in the
full sense of that term to speak a
divine word at
that moment but those are the limit
experiences where people often have the
most powerful sense of God of the
unconditioned and some people are able
to say like I I had a couple of brain
tumors and I went through lymphoma and
people would and and whenever people
come to my office and say you know how
did how did you feel because people
always come to rob and say why me right
always yeah I said look what I was
thinking was I was born in the richest
country in the world I had parents who
loved me I was never hungry why me I
mean that's what I was asking why me the
other stuff it's like I don't expect and
I don't think any of us should expect an
uninterrupted we're on a blessing but
what we can to do is we count everything
that's good in our lives as natural and
everything that's bad as unfair yeah
obviously there are radically unfair
things but for most of us I mean we're
very lucky yeah to be here mm-hmm just
very lucky yeah just on a purely
personal level not just the sort of idea
level there's got to be those moments
that you know not just when you're 26
but even now where someone presents
something to you and it's like where
where do you guys just get that just
sort of fortitude and energy to get up
and have to be strong when you just
don't feel like I know what it's like
doing what I do I have been dealing with
Syria Haiti has a different answer yeah
all right I mean mine mine is the Holy
Hour so I mean I begin every day with an
hour of prayer most of it in silence
before the Blessed Sacrament I mean so
it's just this time of of communion with
the Lord and I I'm a morning guy I wake
up early and so before any distractions
come in I'll spend an hour with a cup of
coffee and the tabernacle you know so
it's just a time of communion and that's
where I bring all this stuff to the Lord
I'll bring what I'm worried about I'll
bring people's needs and concerns people
say all the time you know the priests
and bishops pray for me I'll pray for me
so I try to do that like Lord I don't
remember all their names but every one
that asked me to pray for them I'm now
doing it you know but that's for me
super important because you're
absolutely right there are times like I
don't know what to say I don't know what
to say however years ago a young priest
and there was a a man who had killed
himself before killing himself had
killed his son
and this made the papers you know I was
at the funeral parlor not attending that
wait but another one from my parish but
on the way out I noticed these two
coffins in the room it's very unusual
you know and then I saw the name and
dance so I went in you know and at the
wife and mother saw me had the collar on
she comes over and she went like okay
you know religious guy right I did that
and that was it I mean I didn't say one
word to write it I didn't know what I
could say but somehow weirdly you know
this just the the presence of a
religious representative going like look
I don't know I mean I don't know either
but but somehow there's a context of
something here that we're both
acknowledging through all of this
darkness so that's what you face pastor
Lee I mean I think that aful idea that
presence is more powerful than answers
yeah answers are but presences but I was
gonna say is that I think actually part
of what part of what I find is what I'm
sure you find you think oh my god I
can't believe I mother got to do another
podcast today and you drag yourself in
here
but then the doing brings its own
powerful energy and so there are times
when I'll say I can't believe I got to
go through a wedding I can't believe I
got to go do a few I really don't want
to get up I really don't want to get
dressed but there is never a time when
I'm standing up and doing it where I
don't think oh my god I'm so blessed to
be able to do this because there is in I
am a I'm a big advocate of what used to
be called the james-lange theory of
emotion which is not that you feel
something and then you do it but you do
something and it really will then rise
and swell to fill the moment and that's
what happens do you the one that comes
my mind is the somme they go out they go
out full of tears caring see for the
sowing they come back they come back
full of song carrying the sheaves that
to me is pastoral experience very often
is you you're driving to the hospital
you're like I don't want to go and you
kind of full of tears about it but then
you come back you come back singing
right I think the car singing is that
there's something it did something to
you and I think James is right as well
it must feel nice for you guys just to
be able to admit that briefly because I
think people probably look at you guys
it's that woman going like this yeah
right like that you're these like
superhuman things or something or that
you're supposed to know everything and
give them everything right so just a
moment where you can admit oh I was in
the car and this or I didn't wanna get
out of bed it probably just for you guys
so it's a little therapy you're it's
hopefully yeah I don't even have a
question for this but I just thought
this was an interesting thing that
happened to me about two months ago
Jordan and I you know we're on tour
together we were in Salt Lake City and a
couple came up to me before the show and
they they just looked they're very sad
and disturbed and they came up to me and
they said this was their one night out
there they've been dealing with a lot
her father had just died within the week
he had been diagnosed the guy that I was
standing that had been diagnosed I think
with testicular cancer and that she was
pregnant with their baby that they had
been told was not going to live but the
child was still in utero and I did I
mean I truly I had one of those moments
where I had no idea what to say it was
like slow motion I was like they you
know I gave a ID I'd given them tickets
to my meeting right after not knowing
any of this so when I came up to them I
was like you know right being all
friendly and everything and I did not
know what to say and it was and I just I
just said god bless you guys I could not
like it was like the only would seem
like the only word that had any value
whatsoever so I don't even have a
question for that it was interesting
that it was just what there was nothing
left in my brain to say and that's what
you said though right yeah it's very
interesting to me because I mean
somewhere in your in your soul those
words came out you know even if and I
guess you know from what you've said
explicitly your non-believer right at
this point I wouldn't say I'm a
non-believer he was before the pot I
think that's really worth just
meditating on it that came from
somewhere in your developing psyche and
soul or whatever and that's very
powerful it seems to me and I'm what I
would say to you is I mean yes what you
told them was the only thing you can
really tell someone who's suffering
which is you're not alone mm-hmm that's
that is the ascent
human message you're not alone god bless
you use you responded you were present
in their moment of pain and and there's
nothing else that someone can ask of you
yeah it was it was certainly powerful
alright so I want to wrap with some
let's give some people some concrete
steps to have these conversations for
themselves do you guys have any tricks
and I and I really mean this sort of
with within the realm of what your last
book was about to help people do some of
this online it's one thing when they
come to your offices it's one thing when
when we sit here and do this but in the
online world which we've already
discussed there's some great things
going on and some terrible things going
on how do people do this because it's
just a litany of you know you know
one-upping each other and taking each
other down and the rest of it are there
tricks that you guys have found that
that you think can make these
conversations a little more effective I
suppose well I it sort of the practical
level they're sort of grander
philosophical things where you say about
it but at the practical level that that
thing I said earlier is always realize
you're dealing with a person behind the
words it's it's so easy to say look
those words are wounding me and so I'm
gonna respond you know with wounding
words of my own there's a person there's
a person there's a person behind those
words but secondly I mean to move out of
a purely emotional ambit I've nothing
against the emotions but if you stay
purely when the emotional an but we
start doing this this back and forth you
know you've hurt me I'll hurt you
is there something of objective truth
that we can talk about so even as you're
objecting to me as people often do you
know I think okay really really smart
people in the great tradition have held
the central thing you're saying even
within all this kind of jumbled language
or highly charged emotion there's a
there's an argument in there there's
that there's a truth claim being made
can you identify that and do in a way
that is very affirming what I hear you
saying through all of this is this and
ask you to say lots of really smart
people have held this position do I have
that right and like that kind of
response I find can just disarmed
people and and can break through some of
the emotion the emotionality and try to
now we can begin to have an argument we
can start talking about the truth claim
being made it is it is useful to
remember that no one wins arguments
they're fun to have but it's almost
argument as a process of convincing
yourself that you were right I've almost
never walked away from an argument
saying yeah he was right I was wrong he
out argued me I'm done and so if you
realize that if you argue with the
person if you resist the the desire to
just argue and you resist the desire to
be clever which is really hard it really
are you think of a clever response and
to not say it my father used to tell me
that there's a Yiddish phrase who is a
hero one who resists a wisecrack and and
I'm not at all heroic yes and then you
use the magic there is a magic tool with
human beings have which is the question
you just asked a question instead of
arguing or you do you say what do you
think about this or how do you feel
about that it's remarkable how powerful
a question can be hi Ravi who was a
Nobel Prize winning physicist at the end
of his life in Haaretz of paper in
Israel they said to him who was the
greatest influence in your life and he
said my mother because when I used to
come home from Heder which was Jewish
religious school in Eastern Europe every
day she would say to me yet see did you
ask any good questions today and I
always thought that was great so you
learn to ask questions and you might be
amazed that people tell you things yeah
and the respect for your opponent I'm
thinking now with this conversation
between a rabbi and a Catholic bishop my
hero Thomas Aquinas who read everybody
and dialogue with everybody the
Christian tradition of course but also
pagan philosophers and scientists also
the Muslim scholars also most of my mana
days always refers to Maimonides is Ravi
Moy says always your first and very
respectfully you know which is not the
Communist attitude in the Christian
Middle Ages but there is a quaint as
having this seminar conversation with
all these different voices and speaking
with great respect of them and to them I
think that's a great model for us now
all right so I do have one bonus one for
it which is since we're right between
Hanukkah and Christmas right now I have
always personally liked when Hanukkah
and Christmas were at the same time like
then everyone's sort of celebrating the
exact same time and it's like whatever
the differences are it just doesn't
matter everyone's getting presents on at
least one of the same days something
like that this year Hanukkah was all
they always say it's right well you
probably do a show on that they tell you
the Jewish holidays are but let's say
early I'm just curious if you have
either one have you ever thought of that
whether it would you like it better when
they fall out together because maybe
there's something in a wider community
or does it not matter at all I know I
mean I look I I really I've always been
a fan of Christmas
I enjoy Christmas I like Christmas music
I especially like the Christmas music
that was written by Jews it was no it's
not and I think that the reason that I
like Christmas is because when your
hands are full so you don't feel like
you need a handout you can enjoy other
people's religious tradition when you
feel secure in your own and so it never
felt like a threat to me it always felt
like a beautiful holiday and I loved it
and also because of one of the things
that I always tell high school students
which is that you can't spend your life
living in the minds of other people you
know we send so much time worrying about
what other people will think about us
all the time I mean that social media is
so much about what will other people
think about us but the truth is they
probably think about us as much as we
think about them and that's not the way
and at the end of the day you've got to
live with you so that to me is the and
so I I enjoy Christmas knowing it's not
mine and if people don't like that I
feel like okay but they'll send me a
mean email and then they won't think
about me but I'll still be here and
solid answer to a strange question may
be able to say this I have always loved
Hanukkah and what it celebrates the
purification of the temple which i think
is really needed today namely a recovery
of worship you know I think people need
a sacred space they need a temple a
place to pray and what's happened in the
hyper secularized world is they've lost
the sense of where do I go where do I go
to pray and the temple needs to be
reclaimed and purified so I think that's
a beautiful thing for every one of the
nice things about
there's no Jewish holiday for the
dedication of the temple there's only a
Jewish holiday for the rededication of
the temple and when we talk about the
renewal of religion what we're really
talking about is Hanukkah hmm well
gentlemen it's been an absolute pleasure
I thank you guys doing this tape this is
a busy season for you guys I hope when
you guys were driving here well I hope
when you were driving here you were like
oh I don't have to do that you were when
you woke up this morning oh my god now
we go back carrying the shoe thank you
so much we're gonna link to to your
books down below and all that good stuff
okay thank you guys for watching and
comment right down below maybe they'll
read it there
[Music]